Daniel: Next up -
Welcome Avel.
We have Avel Guénin-Carlut with “Embedded
normativity.”
So thanks Avel to you.
Avel: Hello.
Can you hear me?
Daniel: Yep.
Avel: And can you see the slides?
Daniel: I only see the top left of the
slide.
Avel: You only see the top just yeah.
Daniel: Try again.
Thank you.
Avel: Okay, about now?
Daniel: Yep.
Looks great.
Thank you.
Avel: Okay, good.
So I am Avelina Carlo.
I'm interested in multiscale collective
organization.
This is why I came to active in France to
begin with.
And the core question I've been asking is
basically when we look at human
organization, there is creative evolution,
, there is a change through time of the
specific patterns that are enacted.
And this is very hard to account for.
And I have been trying to pin down more
and more specifically what exactly is
going on and how to model it.
So this specific work is a work I wrote
in the context of my PhD.
Of course, which is funded by the Escape
Project, a project in cognitive
archaeology that's interested in how the
archaeological landscape shape cognition
and vice versa.
The title of it is automated.
No activity.
An active inference of agency.
An active inference account of agency
being flesh because you will see very
quickly why.
So first we will go through the existing
work on anchor cognition in the context
of active inference.
Then we'll try to expose the concept of
embedded Motivity, which we introduce
here and what it means.
And then we'll look at the more semiotic
question around the externalization and
utilization of normativity in cultural
landscapes.
So first encouraged cognition in active
in France.
So we know active inference.
I will go quickly over it.
I still need to do it because there are
lookers that are not familiar.
So active inference say that agents
continuously predict the specific queues
sensory cues they will see, and they
predict the action or policy they will
not take.
And they basically enact an ongoing
stream of expectation that they
reconstruct given upcoming signal.
So this is best Akotin four in this
schema which shows the agent as the
nickel system, which engage through
environment, through action and
cessations.
And all of these specific domains, they
minimize a specific function that is
called free energy and whose minimization
basically means there is a prerogative
process going on.
And a core property of active inference
is that it dissolves agency as we
typically understand it.
We don't have agents that have like an
internal monologue that drives them to
take decision.
We have a conscious anticipation of what'
's going on.
And whatever an agent anticipates itself
to do, it will do.
And so this goes for computationally
satisfying but very deflationary notion
of what is going on with agency.
So the question then comes what is the
relation between an agent and the
cognitive landscape in which it evolves?
I will present very rapidly again the
framework of Skill and a pioneered by
Brunborg, Kierstein and Reidfield, and
which says that Skill agents, which we
understand as agents that understand what
is going on around them, they will
basically experience the world as a
landscape of affordances, which is
opportunities for actions and their
cognition pretty much reduces to the
experience of this landscape and adaptive
engagement with it, which basically
maximize the grip the agent has on the
system and essentially for reasons we
will not go over because it's math the
very existence experience of this
landscape.
It is equivalent to the existence of
constraints over attention.
The attention that the agent gives to
thing which translates the embodied
expectation that are two times embodied
bad the embodied expectation that the
agent enacts.
And so this becomes very interesting when
we cross it with the existence of
enculturation in humans because the basic
experience we have of affordances, of
what we can do it is shaped culturally,
it is shaped by interaction wherein we
learn with other humans about what we do,
what we can do and what we can do.
And this means that the basic human
experience, it's thoroughly encultured.
It's embedded in what Ramshed called
landscape of cultural fondencies and it
is embedded in cultural and material
regimes of attention so ways to pay
attention to things.
And this is a figure that comes, I
believe, from this year on thinking
throughout the minds where it shows
basically how the action installation
cycle.
When we have several agents, they build a
common environment that has epistemic
cues on how the world is like and we are
enculturated to pay attention to things
in a certain manner that makes it so.
We perceive and enact this landscape and
so the uncultured constraint over the
flow of attention because of what we saw
just before the deflationary account of
agency.
It means that the very expensive
landscape, cultural landscape that is
collectively enacted, it effectively
integrates intentionality, it effectively
integrates normativity in a way that
clashes strongly with classical account
of both.
So, given this state of the art, let us
look at what I mean specifically by
embedded normativity.
So embedded Motivity is a kind of
normativity, I think you have got it.
So normativity it means basically the
criterions by which we judge things to be
good and bad in the context of biological
system they will look for specific, I don'
't know, chemical concentration and they
will avoid other this is the phenomenon
of chemotaxis, this is pretty basic and
this is a form of normativity.
But for humans we will typically think of
laws, cultural norms, culturally shared
way to judge behavior and again, at least
in the context of law and choice theory
we typically think there is an agent, he
has access to information and will think
what should I do?
And he will judge rationally about what
is good and what is bad based on a
collection of values which are internal
to the agent.
This is not how it works.
What I call embodied Motivity is by
contrast regimes of normal activity where
it is the norms and value that guide the
agent's behavior.
It is embedded in the material and
cultural environment.
So basically the agent projects a
specific set of norms and value in the
very experienced fitness environment and
it will perceive the locus of normativity
as the environment and not as a form of
internal judgment.
Let us look at what can exactly how
embedded Motivity work.
It will be more concrete.
So first we can materially constrain
people to do things.
So for example, there are roads, you can
go off roads but it's harder and you can'
't really do that if you are a chariot.
So when you have a specific pattern of
roads which is constructed by cities you
are pretty much constrained to follow the
roads materially and for this we will
talk of structural embedding and there is
another regimes of mezzanomativity where
we build on environments that will
basically cue you suggest you into
adopting specific norms and specific
values.
For example, Escape thinks that vertical
patterns in archaeological culture they
are somehow embedded within what we'd
call vertical norms.
So hierarchy and certification in social
relationship and for this specific form
of embedding we can talk of semantic
embedding.
What must be very clear is that we don't
have structural embedding on one side and
semantic embedding there are basically
two mechanism, complementary mechanism in
which embedded normativity occurs.
If we look at city so this is impression
of sumerian culture city states we have
matter organization that prompts specific
kind of behavior.
So for example, we have a bridge and this
bridge allow you constrain you to go
through the river in a specific way if
you are on foot.
But these material constraints it is
perceivable.
So by seeing the bridge you will also see
that you can navigate the world in this
specific way.
So you don't have a sparration between
semantic and structural embedding.
We just have two ways in which
constraints of our behavior that are
embedded in the environment work, and
something that is core to the account of
embedded non activity is, again, that it
is not internal.
But we need to go into more detail about
what we mean by not being internal,
because, of course, we're talking about
agency agents constrain what agents do.
It's not outside what it is is embedded.
In Motivity is a regime of the multivity
where the norms and value, they stem from
the experience of Fordance.
For example, if I see fire I will not
think about hey, could I put my hand in
it and get my hand burn?
I think it would be painful.
I won't do that.
If I even think about putting my hand in
the fire I will immediately feel bad.
The normativity it's embedded in my
experience of the world.
I feel like the fire or more specifically
the possibility of putting my hand in the
fire is intrinsically bad.
I do not feel there is a possibility that
is neutral and then I judge to be bad.
But of course this judgment does not
occur outside even if I feel like it's
about my affordances.
It emerges from the engagement I have
with the material and cultural niche in
which I find myself.
And if we want to untangle what this
means precisely we will have to go into
more detail into what I call the
externalization internalization of many
normativity.
So let us look at something very simple
how normativity work for embodied agents.
.
So embodied agents, they do things
hopefully in a niche that is material and
this niche will be marked by the activity
of my agent.
And these marks, they can then act as
constraints either through structural or
cementing embedding in the agent's
firmament because they basically signify
that in the past I wanted to do that.
Maybe doing that is good.
For example, we have centuries with I don'
't know if centuries English word but web
path if animals that have legs this is
actually important walk on a specific
path, they will compact the earth and it
will become improper to grow anything,
even grass.
And you will have paths that will emerge
that are pretty neat, it's pretty visible
and that tell you hey, not only this
earth is compact and allow you to walk on
it without effort but also this has been
widely judged to be a good outline for
navigation in this specific environment.
So the very experience of a path
basically invites you you perceive the
affordance of walking through the path
and this is something that again can
result from your own activity that can be
written into development by your own
activity.
And so this begs the question of how okay,
, there exists embedded nomativity but
how do we embed nomativity?
What is the activity of embedding
mativity like?
And the word I will use for that is
externalization.
We perceive the world because we
externalize specific causes of sensation
into an imagined objective external world.
.
So when we see the path, we see a path.
We do not see compact earth that we then
compute to mean that other things have
worked on it.
We just see hey, there is a path.
And this is because we have externalized
a specific cognitive kind which is the
path.
And this is argument that several people
made here lene Steiner, which if I
remember well, worked on the production
of devices that help blind people see
things through, I believe an array of
repetitive device on their shoulder.
So the core argument they make is that if
you give people that they will start
seeing things, they will start perceiving
things as being before them rather than
having vibration on the shoulder and then
thinking about what does it mean.
And so the basic argument is that
perception is just picture of what cause
we infer, what is the structure we infer
of our environment given the existence of
a specific coupling device that relates
action to sensation and vice versa.
And this critically relies on the
internalization of specific.
We could say a lot of things that I will
say priors specific, priors knowledge and
perception.
So me seeing the path as a path relies on
me having the prior knowledge that there
is such a thing as paths and I should be
expecting to see them around.
And so you have duality of
externalization and internalization in
the production of embedded mativity.
I can only see norms out there if I've
internalized integrated a specific
apparatus of perception that entails that
there are indeed those specific norms
that are embedded in those specific
affordances.
And so this produce a more general
question of semantics, particularly of
information theory.
How do reading and writing and reading
maturity works?
So when I extend lies I treat the world
as having specific natural categories
that I pretty much imagine and I can use
them because I imagine them as an
extended memory that allow me to read and
write normative cues.
This can be letters, pure signs.
But as far as I'm concerned here, all
signs are at least implicitly normative.
There about how you should interpret the
sign.
And this means that we can experience
specific landscape of forensics and we
can write things out there.
We can write normative cues, bio behavior
that will then constrain further behavior.
.
But nothing tells us that we can
communicate through this.
The communication, it works because of
the internalization of prayers.
If a given community of agents have
internalized a specific set of prayers
that is, a set of prayers that enable
externalization of numerative cues, then
only it can use the environment as a way
to write and read.
Normative queues as embedded normativity
thing.
And this communication, it can be read in
terms of information theory.
Of course it can be read in terms of
semantics.
But what is critical to analyze that the
process of internalization there is no
trust system there is no private key that
allow you to be sure that the way you
internalize norms is very specifically
the way in which the Emily Mativity was
encouraged to begin with.
There is a loss, or there is ambiguity,
or there is I'd rather say it like this
an active demarch of reconstruction, of
given prayers by the agent.
And so this gap between the intent of
other communicants and my intent, my
understanding of what they meant by their
active engagement with the world, it
builds a tiny gap in information that is
somehow enough to drive the open ended
evolution of cultural landscape.
And this is something that I do not think
is embedded in active in France and I
think is of major interest to research,
to the research at least in the evolution
of open end evolution of cultural
landscape.
So to sum up things, I just presented a
paper that is called anomaly Motivity and
that speaks unsurprisingly of embedded
normativity.
First major point is that if active
inference is correct, then our notion of
agency is dissolved essentially in the
notion that we can perceive and enact
cognitive landscape.
Umvelt, if you want.
And given that this is the case, we will
experience the norms and value that guide
our behavior as a property of the
cognitive landscape.
We experience the affordance that we can
perceive and this specific regime of
normativity I call embedded normativity.
And the third thing is that you have a
critical thing going on.
You have a semiotically constraining
thing going on in the externalization and
internalization of regimes of embedded
mativity because those two things they
respectively enable embedded Motivity to
exist, to have a causal power and they
enable also the open ended evolution of
the norms that are embedded in a given
landscape in a given material landscape
and therefore the open end evolution of
the asseted, cultural or committee
landscape.
So thank you.
I will enroll my references slides in
case someone really needs to know what
the reference is and is ready to move
around the video for this.
And do you have questions?
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you.
Avel, while people are typing any
questions, could you maybe just give a
little introduction to the active
inference for the Social Sciences
course?
Like, what brought you to want to
facilitate this effort and where are we
at and where do you want it to go?
What do you want it to be for?
Oh, mute and then continue.
Avel: Good point.
Thank you.
The Active Inference Institute organizes
and kerose Research organize a course on
active inference in the social science
that is based essentially in explaining
the basic demarch, the basic hypothesis
and the consequences of the cultural
landscape formalism that I hinted at
slightly in this presentation.
The goal of the course is to give basic
ontology that is an interface between
complexity science, let us say physics,
written large cognitive science and
social science to afford
interdisciplinary collaboration in the
social science and in the study of the
evolution of human societies.
And I think it is cool, but I'm biased
because I've missed it.
So maybe you should ask Daniel, which is
absolutely unbiased, whether the course
is cool.
Daniel: I've been enjoying it a lot.
We just finished last week with my
section on collective behavior.
First we had the introduction lecture
from you, then Ben White on the basics of
being an active agent.
And we have Lorena and Mao's sections
upcoming, as well as your more dedicated
session.
Yeah, it's been a really fun experience
and it's going to provide a really useful
missing piece in the ecosystem, I guess.
Just one question.
How do we take some of these topics you'
're bringing in about the embedded
normativities and think about them
digitally?
Like, are we talking about conceptual
embeddedness in information environments
and or are we talking about the
ergonomics of sitting at our desk?
Or how do we bring that kind of pleasure
path stigma g on the ground into the
digital are we talking about something
that's embodied and embedded in the
information space or are we still talking
about bodies?
Avel: So if we talk about humans, we talk
about bodies with the brain that do
things in a mature environment.
But your question is I'm not sure
understood is how can we bring this
specific concept in the study of digital
phenomena?
I cannot.
Twitter internet.
Daniel: Is that it?
Yeah.
Avel: Okay, so you have basically the
whole study on the affordances, the
discipline of design has incorporated a
while ago the national affordance in its
structure.
And most of the study in the digital
design centers are on what platforms
afford or do not afford.
And you have richer stance when you take
into account not what you can do with a
specific interface, but what the specific
interface invites you to do.
Given a set of cultural written large, it
can be self learning, but given a set of
power that you share with the platform in
a way that is formal but indirect yes.
I would look at it in terms of user
interface design.
I think this concept specifically is
useful for interface design.
Then you have implicitly the question of
the flow that platforms such as, I don't
know, twitter.
Facebook how specific structure
environments bring specific collective
dynamics that may be a bit richer.
Not richer specifically, but that may go
in.
A direction that the user face question
do not go into and that can still be
modeled in terms of constraints and
therefore in terms of embedded
normativity.
Is that on point?
We'll go to your question.
Daniel: Yeah, that's interesting about
what the interface does and then what it
invites.
It might invite things.
In order for that invitation to be
fulfilled, it has to actually provide
that possibility.
But it might invite things that aren't
relationally possible.
Like there might be a wall which invites
climbing to a given observer, yet they
cannot climb it.
And then on the other side is a capacity
that isn't invited and that is the
adjacent possible of tool use where
something that was being used for this
purpose, it's like all of a sudden it
just fell out of someone's hand.
They grasped it a different way, it
invited a different engagement.
And then that can become re entrenched
and that points to that sequential making
and breaking of new spaces that your work
has featured over the last few years.
Avel: Yes, exactly.
This work has been developed while
thinking about tool use, while thinking
about cognitive archaeology, while
thinking about the experience of cities,
the way urbanism prompts specific
behavior.
But if I can get back on the Internet
thing, I'd like to make it more specific.
.
So the interface design, as far as I know
is focused on interface.
That is not surprising, but in doing so
it is focused on specific fordance and
what you can do.
You have another layer in ecological
psychology, which is the layer of
solicitation.
So, for example, Twitter does something
very specific, which is when you log in,
it shows you the number of notifications
you have, then it removes it and you have
to wait to know which were those
notification.
And you have to wait not 1 second, not 1
minute, but a random amount of time.
So this is what they call dark patterns.
They are patterns in design that are
explicitly designed to create addiction.
So this is a layer you can't afford in
affordance, because from an affordance
perspective there is just a moment you
can access the information and then a
moment you can't, and then the moment you
can again, there is nothing going on.
If you don't look at intrinsic motivation
and the way specific structure,
environment is perceived, the semantics,
maybe the meaning that given landscape
has for an agent.
And even if you look at this, you are
still looking at the platform in a way
that is embedded from the specific
patterns, that specific patterns of
things that people do on the platform.
If you have Twitter without the
aggressive QRTs and the way to
aggressively signal that you are in
whatever it is, is going on, you don't
have Twitter much, you have Mastodon
maybe that has very similar affordances
and very dissimilar solicitation.
So this is why you have to take
multiscale account of things.
And when you take multiscale account of
things you have to look at the semiotics
basically behavior, how specific
coordination occur at specific scales
around specific communication, specific
message passing.
And once you look at how specific message
become meaningful to specific agent, you
have a problem basically because this is
subjective, this is constructed through
the activity of the agent and whatever is
the range of time you are looking at, you
will have the construction of new
possibilities of adjustment possibles as
you put it.
And and yeah, this is the big question
that I think we are missing at the moment
in active inference.
Daniel: Awesome.
Well, thank you for this presentation.
Thanks for the social sciences work and
we're all looking forward to seeing how
the projects play out.
Avel: Thank you.
Goodbye.
Daniel: Farewell AVO.